servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen serie
worum es heute geht das er gleich jetzt
direkt mal gelesen dass die serie wild
west eis und das hat damit mit folgendem
zu tun
es geht um ein bonvivant duell im
klassischen western stil und das läuft
folgendermaßen ab ich bin mir immer mit
einem gegner heute mit dem logo
einschreibung in einer runde
und wenn jetzt die runde startet hat
jeder fünf minuten zeit
ich nehme die zeit hier auf mit meinem
handy hat jeder fünf minuten zeit zeit
startet jetzt gleich um sich equipment
zu suchen nach diesen fünf minuten
trifft man sich wieder am spot- und
damit gekämpft
das sind die regeln von wild wings und
ich das ist ein mega die tatsächlichen
wir letztens eingefallen als mit einer
runde aufgenommen hat und daum hatte
lustigerweise auch die genau die gleiche
idee hat auch gesagt gerner witzig coole
sache und hat aber gesagt ja macht das
weil ich habe projekt mäßig schon genug
auf meinem channel so und wissen jetzt
in der 64er runde album heißt es gibt
echt extrem viel davon es gibt richtig
gut gekämpft und wir verteilen die
weltgeschichte der timer läuft und dann
gleich kommen wir wieder
und dann wird gekämpft dann gibt es
keinen sich davor drücken dann gibt es
keinen weg rennen dann willst du sporn
gegangen und dann wird gefeiert heute
und ich freue mich richtig darüber so
dass das irgendwie diesen diesen einfall
hatte weil ich finde es ist eine mega
coole idee und dem logo auch schon
gemeint ja voll witzig lassen machen
und ja ich kann natürlich auch jede
menge youtuber hier ein laden in dieses
projekt das ist eigentlich perfekt und
der erste gast heute ein logo ich habe
schon in der als auge gefasst dass ein
tier mit dom zu machen
mit max natürlich gerne mal ansonsten
könnt ihr gerne gerne gerne gerne gerne
eure youtuber in die kommentare
schreiben
ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen aus
luton konzentrieren gleich wirklich gut
über gegen dich mal hier ein eine runde
wild west machen soll
duell wie im wilden westen oder wie max
sagen würde eine kugel reicht man wie im
wilden westen
so jetzt zwar ein langer langer monolog
ihr könnt ihr links gleich wenn ihr
jetzt schon in die kommentare schreiben
welchen die gerne mal sehen wird
schreibt doch auch direkt in die
kommentare was eine gute map ist ich mit
logo spielen könnte wenn halt so so
harms vorgeschlagen die abhörsicherheit
werden spaß hat dass ich mich total in
die hose pässe weil ich muss auch sagen
horror ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt mein
mann genre mainz auch nicht plötzlich
auf muss spare ich mir gut ich habe auf
meinen kopf maps geschaut da gibt's der
kategorie passen die gefällt mir sehr
gut
deswegen schreibt das alles mal in die
kommentare nächste kommentare durch und
dann liegt der beste kommentaren
sternchen kickte alter zweites neues
ich habe 18 wie sieht es bei dir aus wie
es weiter aus ja ich habe einen
raketenstart sie gefunden
also das wird dann so nasa starten also
kollaps kurz nach dem namen machen
nachdem es losgeht oder das wissen ja
einer wir sind ja heute auf dem kometen
gelandet welchen stream 20 minuten lang
wie die dort in der esa saßen und dort
koordiniert haben wie diese raumsonde
auf dem kosten kometen landen
8 wie macht er jetzt auch live streams
sowie alles vom spiel geklaut
leute ich wirklich übrigens riesig
riesig freuen wenn ihr mit einem like
ausdrückt was ich von diesem projekt
haltet also schreibt einfach in die
kommentare was ihr von haltet habt ihr
verbesserungsvorschläge in irgendeiner
richtung mehr zeit fürs equipment finden
weniger zeit fürs equipment finden
mit masken spielen keine ahnung mit
karneval zu hüten irgendwas alles was
ich ein feld in die kommentare ich ließ
mir alles durch versprochen und dann
können wir dieses projekt zusammen
entwickeln und noch weiter verbessern
ist jetzt erst mal die beta phasen aber
ich wollte es mit
auch eineinhalb minuten logo wie sieht
es bei dir ja wohl die folie legend
schon irgendwie fast denken das release
and the times lewis weiß ich mache ich
vielleicht schön fertig werden
der bogen wird dir in die preise
gedrückt dann richtig ab mit gehörig
vernascht ich hasste gehört ist auch
nicht ich glaube viele goldene äpfel
hast die deftige speisen goldene äpfel
nur drei das ist er manchmal eine
schwäche auch wieder 80 80 80 ist so
eine schöne runde zahlen dann 8 ich
nehme ich mal moment mal wo willst du
wissen dass du 80 apple hast dafür
müsstest du ja ein stack und noch ein
zweites zusammen rechnen können deine
mentale fähigkeiten also da ist was faul
lassen hast du etwa die unwahrheit
gesagt passt etwa die unwahrheit gesagt
noch 20 sekunden
wenn die wenn die ludwig teil vorbei ist
hat man keine kiste mehr öffnen einige
keine kiste öffnen okay und dann hab
aber eben auch mal zehn sekunden ist so
ein scheiß kiste oder oma haben
eigentlich alles okay luc ihm vorbei und
stoppt und jetzt geht's los ich habe ein
kompass ich geh auf dich zu und wenn wir
uns sehen geht der fall direkt los ja ja
und dann hast du dich nicht mehr
aussagen
die kisten gehen müssen
darf ich nicht mehr dran gehen leute da
habe ich nicht mehr daran gehen und
jetzt gleich kommt der erste erste
entfällt hier in wild west gegen den
logischen schritt genau jetzt in die
kommentare wer diese runde gewinnen was
glaubt ihr vestberg vip logen oder ich
ja der hübschen das bin ich in der
schule so pause machte instagram auf und
sie einfach deine ballon d'or fünf leute
er ist jetzt da irgendwer irgendwo ist
irgendwo er ist irgendwo also ich hab
jetzt die gelegenheit schreiten die
kommentare
rettet den gewinn machen noch kurz des
kurses ist jeder irgendwo sein oder ich
glaube die ganze auf dich zu hast du
einen kompass ja der kompass aber zu
schön für die routinemäßig routinemäßig
okay leute jetzt habt ihr zeit gab es in
die kommentare schreiben
wo ist da wo ist er wo bist du logo
slogan mein kompass ich guck dich genau
an
du kannst mich gar nicht angucken möchte
ich nicht sehe
laut kompass coop ich dich aber an java
hat meinen augen nicht als er hat meinen
augen sein was meine augen sein meine
augen gibt es gibt schon länger ein
kompass diesen zuverlässiger so wo ist
da wo ist wo ist übrigens direkt hier
auch leiser passten sich an irgend ein
hausdach versteckt oder in lüge ich bin
niemals den reaktor turm hoch gegangen
wo ist da wo ist der leute wo ist der
typ hat der fakten ist einer hinten ist
okay wenn wir erst einfach besser mit
bogen
noch ein gold apfel immer treibt ein
leben übertreibt dein leben
wie hoch ist der kleine hase von olaf h
der kleine hase anzünden der kleine hase
auf die schnauze kommt das thema richtig
gut
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
das tnt war richtig gut kommt ja jetzt
mal fix waren zu brennen jetzt aber okay
wir weiterhin alles übrigens auch gerne
mal an darunter mitmachen
falls ihr wäre mir gerne mal dabei haben
wollt schreibt das in die kommentare
leute woanders war eine geile erste
folge alter alter alter wie viel du ein
gesteckt hast ne 2 gold 3 x gold leute
ich will jetzt gar nicht mehr viel sagen
wird sich gefallen lassen daumen nach
oben da schreibt in die kommentare
welche verbesserungsvorschläge gehabt
und welche max erkennt die gut sind
jedoch keine gespräche player für mich
und dann sehen wir mal der nächsten
folge wieder lassen daumen nach oben da
wenn sich gefallen hat haut drei masken
und ciao